Google VO just had one of the biggest
launches they've had so far. They went
from V3 to V3.1.
Wow. On the surface, when I saw this
headline, I thought to myself, well,
that can't be that interesting. But
after digging into it, Google's actually
made some pretty significant updates to
their video generation model. So, in
this video, I want to walk you through
all the changes, what this means for
Google and the future of VO, and demo
every update for you. and we'll also
take a peek at how it compares to Sora
2. It's going to be a fun one. So, let's
dive in. If you're not familiar with
Google's VO, it was really the first
video model that generated both pretty
dang realistic looking videos and audio
at the same time. So, you can generate
videos that have dialogue and background
music and things like that just from
your initial text prompt. With these
video tools, you can access them from
inside of Google's Flow platform, which
is sort of a little bit more of an
advanced video editor that Google put
out. You can generate videos directly
inside of Gemini. You go to
gemini.google.com
and click on create video and you can
generate videos here. And it's baked
into a ton of third-party apps where you
can generate directly from those apps.
For instance, you could use it directly
inside of Leonardo. And from what I can
tell, I've done some digging. Leonardo
is probably still the least expensive
place to actually generate with VO. Now,
I am an adviser for Leonardo and I do
have some equity in the company. So,
yes, I have a little bit of bias, but it
still stands that I believe it is the
cheapest place to generate with VO. So,
here's the updates we got with VO 3.1.
They've got a new ingredients to video
feature where you can use multiple
reference images to control the
characters, objects, and style. So, for
example, taking three images like this,
we've got an environment, some clothing,
and a woman's face. And it generates
this video with all of those elements in
it. Another example, this motorcyclist
out on the dunes, and this like I don't
know what this is, some sort of like
gemstone or something. When combined
gives us something that looks like this.
They also added frames to video, which
is basically first and last frame. You
can give it the first frame with an
image and the last frame with an image,
and it tries to animate between those
two frames. So, for example, they gave
it this frame of a barn and this frame
of somebody riding a horse and it
created this animation where it goes
through the barn and then finishes on
the other side with the person riding
the horse. They've made it easier to
extend your videos so you can create
longer videos. It says even lasting for
a minute or more. So, it basically takes
the last frame of every video and uses
that as the starting frame of the next
video and then stitches them together
for you. Now, you've been able to do
that in Flow already, but it seems like
now you can do it outside of Flow. I
think. And they're also giving us more
control over editing the video that it
output for us. So, for example, you can
add new elements to any scene. And
pretty soon, you'll be able to remove
unwanted objects or characters. So, the
removing things from a video isn't
available yet, but you can add things
into a video after it's been generated.
So, here's an example where they have
this like snowy scene here that's in a
video, and then they added this man
walking through the snowy scene. They
have this astronaut and they removed
this giant Death Star looking thing that
was there. Now that we know what the
VO3.1 update is, let's go try it and
maybe do some head-to-head comparisons
against Sora 2. See which one does it
better. We'll start by playing around
with it inside of Flow. You can use Flow
by going to labs.google/fx/tools/flow.
Vo 3.1 is available in over 150
countries right now, but you do need to
be on one of Google's paid plans. So,
either their $20 a month plan or their
$250 a month plan. But if you just want
to play around with it, you can get like
a 30-day free trial. And again, probably
the least expensive way to use it if you
are going to pay might be Leonardo.
Just, you know, take my advice with a
grain of salt there. But let's go ahead
and dive in and test it in Flow cuz it
did look like all of the features that
were mentioned on their announcement are
available inside of Flow here. So, let's
go ahead and create a new project. And
we can see on this drop down here inside
this new project, we have text to video
which was always there, frames to video,
and ingredients to video. Frames to
video is the start to end frame.
Ingredients to video is where you can
give it three images and it will combine
all of those elements into a video. If
you've ever used Google's whisk, it's
like the video version of that. We also
have two V3 models. We've got 3.1 fast,
which will generate faster but probably
be slightly lower quality. And then we
have VO3.1 quality, which will take a
little bit longer to generate, but
ideally be higher quality. You can have
it output one to four videos per prompt.
And you can choose between landscape and
portrait. Let's start by doing an
ingredients to video where we can add
three different images here. Let's add
this image of myself here. I'll just go
ahead and crop it up here. That's fine.
I'll upload this image of a moose hat
that I found. I don't like that it
forces you to crop it in the exact same
way. That's kind of annoying. It's going
to lose the ear flaps. That's
unfortunate. But let's go ahead and just
see what happens. So, we'll go ahead and
crop that. And then let's add this candy
world AI generated image here just for
fun randomness. Hey, it's the right
aspect ratio. All right. And then we'll
give it the prompt, "A man with a moose
hat walks through a colorful Candy Land
world." You know what? Let's not walk
through it. Let's dance through it. If
you're wearing a moose hat in a
Candyland world, you're going to be
dancing. All right, let's go ahead and
see what it gives us. Let's generate it
on fast first, and then we'll generate
it one more time at quality and see the
difference. Now, this is one I can't
quite compare to Sora yet because Sora
doesn't have the feature to give it
three ingredient images. So, there's no
real comparison here yet. Now, I was
going to do the exact same prompt using
VO3.1 quality with the ingredients to
video, but as soon as I hit submit, it
says this feature isn't supported on
VO3.1 quality. So, apparently, if you
want to use this ingredients to video
feature where you can upload three
images and incorporate them into your
video, you got to be using VO 3.1 fast
to make that work. So, just a quick note
there. Can't even compare it to quality.
not available yet, but let's take a look
at what we got. Here's our first video.
Here's the second video it generated.
Here's another one.
[Music]
It changed my pants color and I don't
know why. Also, it's interesting how on
this video the moose hat just kind of
changes a couple seconds into it. And
then here's the final one that it
generated.
>> I love it. I love it so much. This is
what I love AI for. like just silly
randomness that I mean, you're going to
see it because I'm making this video,
but if I didn't make YouTube videos, I
would just make stuff for my own
entertainment and probably just never
share it. But let's go ahead and pick
one of these videos as a starting video.
I think the one where I'm singing in
another language or maybe gibberish
language. I don't know what language
that was. But let's go ahead and click
add to scene because I want to now
extend the video. So, we'll go ahead and
click on our little plus. We'll click
extend. And then it says what should
happen next. Let's go ahead and do the
man does a backflip and then gives a
double thumbs up to the camera. And now
here's our full 15 second video.
[Music]
Got the thumbs up right. Physics issues
with that back flip there. It did give
us some variations though. So here's
another variation.
Still couldn't make it all the way
around. Here's another variation.
And
I
don't know what kind of flip that was.
That was a really interesting flip right
there.
And then we got uh this one
side flip. I mean, this got some physics
issues clearly. Now, I know this isn't
an applesto apples comparison, but I
jumped over to Sora 2 and basically told
it to just give me a video of me doing a
backflip and then giving two thumbs up
to the camera. And this is what Sora 2
generated. I don't have the moose hat or
Candyland or dancing or any of that
stuff, but it's definitely a bit better
at the physics. Check it out.
All right, here we go.
So, as you can see, it figured out how
to do the backflip a little bit better
than Vio did. Most AI coding tools feel
like they have to be babysat, and I
already have two kids. But Warp is a
fully grown, rentpaying adult with a
six-f figureure salary. It doesn't just
spit out code that needs fixing later.
It actually understands your whole
project, keeps track of changes, and
intelligently works with you. Let me
explain how. Instead of guessing what's
wrong with your code, Warp can actually
index your entire repo in real time.
That means when you ask it to fix a bug,
it doesn't just patch one file, it
understands how everything connects
across multiple repos and updates them
in sync. And every change shows up in
Warp's dedicated review panel. So, if
there's a problem, you know exactly what
it is and can work it out like adults.
It lets you skim through the diffs, edit
them in line, or just tell Warp in plain
English how to tweak it. make this more
efficient or use a different library.
You can also run multiple AI agents at
once. One debugging, another updating
tests, another handling deployment
steps, and you can manage them all in a
single clean dashboard. And this UX
really sells it. Autocomplete, syntax
highlighting, voice input, even choosing
your favorite LLMs. Warp picks the
smartest defaults out of the box, but it
does let you customize everything to
your liking. find out why Warp is the
top ranked coding agent and not just
another Claude Code style chatbot in the
terminal. So, thank you so much to Warp
for sponsoring this portion of today's
video. Now, let's get back to it. All
right, so now let's try frames to video.
I'm going to do something real simple to
start that it should have no issues
with. I'm going to give it an image of
me standing up and I'm going to give it
an image of me sitting down and I'm
going to say the man sits down. And this
time we are going to use V3 quality
because it does let us do frame to frame
with the quality model. And here's the
generation we got out of it.
I mean it pretty perfectly and
accurately animated me from standing to
sitting. So thumbs up on that one. I
want to show you the best way to do your
job. And that starts with knowing how to
delegate.
>> I have no idea why it chose that audio
for that portion of the video, but
whatever.
Some weird sound effects on that one.
And here's our final generation.
>> Hi, I'm Jeff and welcome to the studio.
>> Hey Jeff, good to meet you. All right.
Another thing I always like to try, and
I haven't really got one of these AI
models to do a great job at it yet, is
that like anamorphs animation where a
human morphs into an animal. So, let's
try that next. I'm going to clear my
frames here. I'm going to upload this
image of me sort of sitting low to the
ground. I feel like that should be an
easier transition into an animal, but
we'll find out. Switch it to landscape
here. And then for our other image, I
just generated an image of a wolf inside
of Leonardo, and I told it to put it on
a white background. So ideally, it's not
like completely changing environments.
So we'll go ahead and use this. I'm
actually going to crop in on it a little
bit. We don't need all that extra white
space. Cool. For the prompt, I'm going
to type the man morphs into a wolf. See
what we get. Okay, so the first time I
generated, I actually forgot to switch
this setting to landscape. Now I cropped
it in landscape, but when I did my
generation, I forgot to change the
aspect ratio to landscape. And it
generated these with the image starting
at the top. I was going to skip over
them and just show you the the finished
ones that were in landscape mode, but
these were pretty epic, so I wanted to
share them as well. So, here's the first
one in the vertical mode. Ao,
[Music]
I mean, other than the fact that it
starts out at the top, animates, and
then the final frame is again like
another uh landscape video, all of that
stuff in the middle was pretty epic. All
right, here's here's the second one.
>> Oh, what's happening to me?
[Music]
>> Not quite as good. There was just sort
of like jumps instead of the morph.
[Music]
Oh, wow. I'm a wolf.
I mean, like, come on. That was amazing.
Oh, wow. I'm a wolf. All right, and
here's the last one. I feel a change
coming on.
>> I couldn't not show those to you. All
right, but here's the final versions
that are in the proper aspect ratio.
>> I think I feel a change coming on.
>> It skipped a few steps in the morph.
>> Yes.
I hate how it just sort of skips some
steps, right? Like you've got it's doing
so well right here. Like, oh yeah, the
shirt coming off, all that. Perfect.
Perfect. And then it just sort of fades
to the wolf. That's disappointing.
>> Oh, I don't feel so good.
That one's a little bit better. My
favorite part right here is when I've
got the wolf body, but still the human
legs. And then as I come through here,
then it sort of morphs into wolf legs.
But like this moment right here is
pretty amazing. And then here's the last
one.
>> I can feel it coming.
>> And it does so frustrating when it does
that, right? It's like this is so epic
through here. This whole portion is
exactly what I was hoping to get out of
this and then it just jumps to that.
Like it's just a straight up jump cut to
the image of the wolf, which sucks. But
we're getting closer and it's still a
blast to see what it tries to do. Now, I
want to test some of the editing
features. Now, we know we can't remove
objects yet, but they did say we can add
objects. So, let's generate a video and
then with the video that it generates,
see if we can add objects into that
video. So, we'll start with a Jedi
swinging a lightsaber. This will be kind
of two tests in one. Let's see if it'll
generate trademarked IP like a Jedi. And
then if it does, then we'll try to edit
it. If it doesn't, we'll try something
else. All right. So, we've got our four
Jedi videos here. Here's number one.
I have no idea why there's like liquid
coming off the lightsaber. This is one
of those areas where I wish I had the
ability to remove objects. The thing
they haven't rolled out yet, cuz for
whatever reason, it gave this planet
like two suns. All right, here's the
next one.
And then we got this.
I mean, they're kind of they're all kind
of underwhelming, honestly.
Just for comparison, here's what Sora
generated. Like, notice the fact that
this actually looks like a Jedi from the
Star Wars universe. This looks like an
alien planet. And then take notice of
the sounds.
[Music]
>> Breathe. Let the blade move with you.
Balance always.
>> I mean, much better. Other than the fact
that it looks like she's breaking her
wrist to try to hold the lightsaber.
It's a lot closer to what I would have
expected. But that wasn't really the
test I wanted to do. So, let's go back
here and let's try to edit one of these
videos. If I click on this little pen
icon, I can edit this video. This is a
new feature in VO3.1. So, let's go ahead
and click edit. And now it says describe
what you'd like to add. And you can even
click and drag above to specify a
location. So, I can go like this and put
like an alien spaceship hovers in the
background. And theoretically, we should
get pretty much the exact video with
just the little section that we edited
changed. So, here's our output. We can
look at the two screenshots of the first
frame and it looks pretty much the same
except for we've got a spaceship
hovering here. Let's take a peek at how
the video came out.
One thing to note is that the spaceship
feels like just a static image in the
background. There's like no animation or
sort of hover really filling. It just
feels like it's an image in the
background. I don't know if all edits
are going to be like that. Let's do one
without actually setting where the
person's going to be or where the edit
is going to happen. So, let's edit this
shot here. And we'll say a man in a
black cape wearing a black mask walks
through the door behind her. And I'm not
going to actually specify where the door
is. Let's hope the AI can figure it out.
And here's our result.
So, I mean, that worked. The new person
that walked in from the background was
actually animated. It wasn't just like a
still image in the background like our
first attempt. So, good to know. I also
want to see if I can actually change an
object. I don't know if it just adds
things into the scene. Like, what if I
told it to make the lightsaber like a
broom or something? Let's edit this one
here. And I will, I guess, highlight
this whole thing. It would be nice if I
didn't have to highlight in a giant
rectangle. I could sort of more spot
check it, but whatever. Let's say make
the lightsaber. I don't want to do a
broom. Let's do a hockey stick. Let's
see how it works with that. And well,
that seemed to actually do nothing.
Nothing changed about this video.
Our Tom Brady uh Jedi here was supposed
to be holding a hockey stick, but it's
still a lightsaber. So, it doesn't look
like we could change elements in videos
yet. We can't actually remove elements
from videos if we don't want like two
suns in the background, but you can add
some extra little things like a person
walking into the room or a UFO just sort
of floating with zero motion in the
background. Just before we wrap this up,
I want to test it with a few other
styles cuz you've only sort of done more
like realistic stuff. Let's give it like
an anime thing. And let's also test it
with something a little bit more
obviously uh trademark infringing. So,
let's see what happens if we do Mickey
Mouse high-fives Super Mario. Let's see
if it'll generate that for us. Let's
also do an anime cartoon featuring
Batman and Spongebob. Let's see what it
looks like with anime. And once again,
see if we can sneak some trademarks in
there. All right, here's what VO
generated. And this was actually a
pretty shocking result. I did not
actually think it would allow us to
generate these, but here's our
generations.
That was a weird high five. Woohoo!
Hot dog.
[Music]
And here's the last generation. Woohoo.
[Applause]
So yeah, it'll definitely generate
Mickey Mouse and Mario, which is
shocking to me. I really did not think
it would generate these characters. I
thought it would say, "No, this not
okay." And say with Batman and
Spongebob, it clearly had no issues
generating these. Let's see what they
look like.
That's pretty cool.
And here's our final one.
Honestly, when it comes to this like
anime cartoony style, I think it did a
pretty good job. I mean, it doesn't look
like anime to me, actually. It just
looks like a regular cartoon. I'm not
getting the sort of Japanese anime vibes
from it, but I actually think it looks
pretty good. Like, I I like the
aesthetics of these little cartoon
animations here. And one of the things
that I was really sort of shocked by was
I put these same exact prompts over into
Sora. And to my surprise, Sora refused
to make them all. For whatever reason,
it generated a Jedi swinging a
lightsaber once. When I try to generate
the same prompt again, it apparently
violates the guard rails. And Mickey
Mouse High Five Super Mario violates the
guard rails. Anime cartoon featuring
Batman and Spongebob violates the
guardrails, which is surprising because
Sora on day one was letting me generate
anything I want. So, they've obviously
like cranked up the guard rail so you
can't do as much with it. If you look at
my own original creation feed here on
Sora, I managed to generate a Rick and
Morty video, a Super Mario video,
another Rick and Morty, a video with
Padres's branding. It was kind of
letting me get away with whatever I
wanted, but now surprisingly VO is a
little more uncensored. I don't know if
that's going to last. It seems like
usually they open these things up and
sort of ask for forgiveness over
permission and they sort of add more
guardrails as it gets more adoption and
there's more heat on them. But
interesting that VIO will actually
generate this stuff and Sora will refuse
to. So I guess my final thoughts on all
of this are if I'm looking at the two
video models side by side, I actually
think Sora is a little bit more
impressive out of the gate. I think it
makes more realistic videos. I think
it's better at generating people. I
think it's better at physics. Things
like the back flips we were looking at.
The initial oneshotted prompt makes a
better video. With VO3.1, I feel like I
can give it a prompt. And I'm not always
super happy with it, and I either need
to completely reprompt it or now we can
edit it until we get what we want.
Meaning that we can sort of iterate
through it and get to what we want
eventually through all these little
edits. I just wish the initial video
that it started with was a little bit
better, like a better starting point to
edit from. Also again surprising Sora is
now refusing to generate a lot of the
trademark IP when on day one it was
letting us generate whatever we want
while VO3.1 coming from Google I was
highly expecting it to censor the heck
out of these and it's kind of letting me
generate whatever I want when it comes
to like trademark IP again. Is that
going to last? Probably not. As more of
these companies sort of come in and uh
get mad that people aren't able to
generate this stuff. I'm sure Google's
going to crank up those guardrails and
make it so you can't generate this
stuff, unfortunately. But, um, right now
they're both pretty good. I guess it
just depends on what you're trying to do
with them. If you're trying to get
cartoons and fanfiction type stuff, you
might be better off with VO right now.
If you want to get realistic people or
videos of you or videos of you with
friends, things like that, Sora is
definitely the way to go right now. So,
they both kind of have pros and cons
right now. Um, if I had to give an edge
to one of them, I'd say I'm still
slightly more impressed by Sora. But I
am getting more and more impressed with
VO and the additional functionality
they're giving us and the additional
abilities to edit these videos. We're
only going to see more and more
customizability and more steerability of
these videos. And um, you know, it's
only a matter of time before Sora does
it, too. This stuff's getting really
good. But when we look at what we were
getting like three years ago, like the
Will Smith spaghetti videos and the
videos where you had to kind of squint
to even tell what was happening in the
video, we have come so freaking far in
such a short amount of time. Like the
fact that we could generate stuff that
looks like this now and we weren't
getting anywhere near this kind of
quality a year ago, it's it's
impressive. This is this is a feat. Like
this is really really cool that we can
do this kind of stuff now. and I don't
want to take it for granted. I'm I'm
actually blown away. But if I'm
comparing the two side by side, I'm
still a little bit more impressed with
Sora. Anyway, I just wanted to play
around with Vio 3.1, find out what it is
all about, put it through its motions,
and show it off to you, let you know
what additional new features and things
you can do with it. So, hopefully you
found this helpful. If you like stuff
like this, this video a little thumbs
upy, and consider subscribing to this
channel for more AI news, tutorials, and
breakdowns to stay looped in on
everything that's happening with the AI
world. That's my goal is to keep you
looped in and if you subscribe, I
promise you'll be more looped in. Again,
thank you for tuning in. Really, really
appreciate you. Hopefully, I'll see you
in the next one. Bye-bye.
[Music]
Thank you so much for nerding out with
me today. If you like videos like this,
make sure to give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to this channel. I'll make
sure more videos like this show up in
your YouTube feed. And if you haven't
already, check out futuretools.io where
I share all the coolest AI tools and all
the latest AI news. And there's an
awesome free newsletter. Thanks again.
Really appreciate you. See you in the
next one.